he went mountains fundamental difference
between there a day and the shi'ar dark
matter
they notice that soetebier park or we but
include the particles with you that that
knowledge is so other
mysteries dust that we become dead is
he experiences how you have a festival  x
play all of the things and not just one
we de op the other
en en asami de dag nfi is santing dat
went means that we have some mysterious
component of en en en china universal
detail universe is not really
en islower tennessee over and over surf
edit without  and who forklifts squares
are so ipr inspection theory current not
enough to describe a dark and advice than
with f penguin who and the standard week
and or people's square partly heard that we
well the area oeh dark matter and then
wido not it
that it is a less  typhoon we who become the
famicom polymer idm in real time a sum of
money college set codex plein
happens in galaxy's of free sound is
this sabine talked about those who at
sound discovered is an dere
that is another role before mary what
guests do it is oil universis
planning what happens in
wel the observations of will it
cost with marco real
gold we will soon be deformed and so that
is cost males data using dakmerk to
explain all this phenomenon  very precise
vd in die cues at specific regions of
the things to explain this
report still the same thing and
minus this of work measured water bottle
at afterwards heften I do with old er in
this dark matter and zo this challenge
film in the series sarnath complete  chat
we check off this fan that is perfect the
weather is fierce mystery yes there is for soul
ist ideal on it you need to solve these
poor puss and it is an eye is min 30
solutions already the first one the
people for a butterfly church roof more
negative en gray  and families in detail
en ik toe en de style gravity better and
then ex planning name all those
after the roof and action vermeer would be
in elementary that should be erg
and maybe  i should people this min to
your family collection string theory that
working on a universal app does not
contain that knowledge for a while
or it is boring and or buggy code
dark ergonomics and negative costs tomorrow
consent
that they with a medical university a
thousand look like ours  that ik een en de
stan graff driebergen wel der
zo live to take those people and
motivate them to also work on so
universal des have task and is no at in
de posily kon de blossom en esteem
there is a very important component of a
universe
wie  has to take that shows the safe
will be able to make with with
operating the matches the how you afraid
to have a during positive task and
a4 none of the universal
with your modular
that two days after two svrz ordinary
feller and you have essence  so i give
you your own mouse from
van finado the recent this china that in
such as my case as the guests podcast
fluffy for all times principles die kees
van de leadership tank is one of the many
every w  eek search for last four times and
recently idea to release your 5 podcasts ceiling
soundcloud and itunes to make sure i
never miss lewis